Assuming that you're already using a library--say, the equivalent of one of these libraries on the CPU,
then porting to use one of the GPU libraries is a simple 3-step process.
First, you need to substitute library calls with their equivalent, CUDA library calls.
So if you're using blas, and you call the function SAXPY--
stands for Single Precision AX plus Y,
then you will simply shift that to be a call to cublas SAXPY.
Next, you need to manage data locality,
so if you are going to be running on the GPU, you want the data to already be on the GPU.
So for example you might need to call CUDA Malloc and CUDA Memcpy
to move the data on the GPU where the library can use to it.
Cublas as CUDA cublas Alloc, cublas SetVector, cublas get vector, for getting the result.
And some of the libraries manage this entirely transparently for you, and others you do it explicitly.
And finally, step 3, you want to rebuild and link with the CUDA accelerated library;
for example, calling the compiler with the -L cublas line.